well I'm sorry that you have we talked
about my bad week do you [ __ ] before we
get to your bed we can have a question
yeah I was walking in the kitchen and
there's like a shitload of toothpaste
toothbrushes okay you guys donating no
no no no I'm glad you notice that and
I'm glad that I'm not the only one that
has to deal with the situation Oh God
the group drama drama there's two things
okay she's a normal person yeah okay
that's right bye but she hoards two
things she hoards water and [ __ ]
toothpaste if you buy her the biggest
size toothpaste one day it's gone I'm
not even I'm not even kidding you right
so I bought 20 boxes a today because I'm
[ __ ] tired of going into the [ __ ]
bathroom and having you know what she
did the other day I bought a toothpaste
she used it in two days then she filled
water into the tube to make it seem like
you know some still left Bobby won't
notice yeah yeah that's what [ __ ]
hoarders do and people with diseases
toilet look I
there's I can explain one of my favorite
things to do to decompress when I'm in
the shower is to put a shits on a
toothpaste on a toothbrush sit there
think and chew I chew down that way your
toothbrushes once a week one oh I get
one every week I just sit there and I
chew like a [ __ ] dog teething yeah
and it's one of my waist it's Mike it's
a coping mechanism I've been doing this
since I was younger and you can always
tell if you walk into a bathroom which
one my toothbrush is because it's the
one that's just completely like
dilapidated yeah this is sense you've
known her yeah and with the whole water
thing I think I hide I hide them under
the bed she finds him all the time and
she drinks all my water I have an
obsession with water I need to always
touch it I need I have panic attacks
when I don't have like a bottle of water
next to me I think that I spent most of
my life in the water twice I did two
days for 15 years I need to be I take
two showers a day and I know
it's a California drought but it's for
my sanity and I just um if I could sleep
with a finger inside a cup of water I
would okay yeah it might I have might
have a problem definitely has one
I get why you bought all that now it
makes and I buy I drink probably I'd say
eight of these a day it's I'm not even
kidding you that's the truth
yeah and it's like dude it's like all my
money is going into water bottled water
bottled water utter spring
[Music]